joey's and how does hattiesburg hi joey
how are you
hi dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
well i am 20 years old i own two
businesses one is a startup
the other has been running for about
three years um well
for the one that's been running i owe
176
000 um on the business
104 of that is owner finance loan um 63
of it
is through a bank and then the 9k is
minor debt
well i know the general rule is never to
take out of an ira
however i'm hoping that you'll give me
permission for an exception
um i've got a cd for 64 000 and and
inherited ira for 700 i'm sorry
79 000 not bad okay the inherited ira is
79 and the cds how much
64 000 okay all right uh
the owner finance loan um the one for
104k
said if i paid in full they would take
10 percent off
um meaning i would save 10 400
on principal and another 17 000 in
interest
and my idea is to use that cd put that
towards it and take the other
30 000 out of the ira yeah and inherited
ira i would do that
when did you get the inherited ira oh
um three years ago for my father okay
i'm sorry sorry for your loss there
um you're not hurting anything yeah and
where did the cd come from
same thing same thing um it was life
insurance
okay and what kind of business are you
running at 20 years old that you won 170
000
in debt for um it's a vending machine
business it started out as 260 000.
um and i've been able to get it down to
there you're making money
um yes to be fair during corona it was
barely paying for itself but
nevertheless paying for itself how much
do you make a month gross right now
gross i mean it varies from month month
but
on average 8k
89k yeah okay
so you're making like 30 grand a year
profit
as of right now yes but i've had that's
because a lot of my business taken away
i'm regaining it back
now that kovis is coming to an end
in mississippi
absolutely okay yeah i would have
thought it would be back
mississippi is open it is
but like the schools which is more than
half of my business
oh okay all right
all right that does explain it okay and
now you're out for the summer
exactly that's the reason my average is
so low yeah okay
all right that's helpful because i'm
just afraid for you these are these
numbers scare the crap out of me and
here's
here's the thing yes i would to answer
your question yes i would do this i
would take the cd
and enough out of the inherited and pay
the loan off i would also try to
negotiate down more than a 10
discount because they probably need the
cash
offer them 20 off and just see what they
say all they can do say no all we'll do
is 10
right so just say i'm having to cash out
my dad's
when he passed away inherited ira and
it's making me feel funny i'll do this
if you'll do 20
throw a little emotion in there see what
you can get them to do
and uh here's the thing i want you to
walk away with don't do this again
you won't have another one of these
shots to clean up this mess
next time you get ready to grow a
business or buy a business you pay cash
for it
don't do this again i'm scared
for where you were you're getting a
one-way ticket out don't you go back
that wasn't unclear was it no you you
covered it well